THE REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR OF IOWA.
HER NAME IS KIM REYNOLDS AND SHE
IS RESPONDING TO THE STATE OF
THE UNION ADDRESS.
>> GOOD EVENING.
I'M KIM REYNOLDS, GOVERNOR OF
THE GREAT STATE OF IOWA.
LIKE YOU, I JUST WATCHED THE
PRESIDENT'S ADDRESS.
I LISTENED AS THE GOVERNOR OF
OUR STATE, AS A MOM, AND A
GRANDMOTHER OF 11, WHO IS
WORRIED OUR COUNTRY IS ON THE
WRONG TRACK.
WE'RE NOW ONE YEAR INTO HIS
PRESIDENCY, AND INSTEAD OF
MOVING AMERICA FORWARD, IT FEELS
LIKE PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HIS
PARTY HAVE SENT US BACK IN TIME
TO THE LATE '70s AND EARLY '80s
WHEN RUN AWAY INFLATION WAS
HAMMERING FAMILIES, A VIOLENT
CRIME WAVE WAS CRASHING OUR
CITIES, AND THE SOVIET ARMY WAS
TRYING TO REDRAW THE WORLD MAP.
EVEN BEFORE TAKING THE OATH OF
OFFICE, THE PRESIDENT TOLD US
THAT HE WANT HE TO, QUOTE, MAKE
AMERICA RESPECTED AROUND THE
WORLD AGAIN AND TO UNITE US HERE
AT HOME.
HE'S FAILED ON BOTH FRONTS.
THE DISASTROUS AFGHANISTAN
WITHDRAW DID MORE THAN COST
AMERICAN LIVES.
IT BETRAYED OUR ALLIES AND
EMBOLDENED OUR ENEMIES.
NORTH KOREA IS TESTING MISSILES
AGAIN AT AN ALARMING RATE.
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
RECENTLY WARNED OUR OLYMPIC
ATHLETES NOT TO SPEAK OUT
AGAINST CHINA.
AND NOW RUSSIA HAS LAUNCHED AN
UNPROVOKED, FULL SCALE MILITARY
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
AN ATTACK ON DEMOCRACY, FREEDOM,
AND THE RULE OF LAW.
NOW ALL AMERICANS MUST STAND
UNITED IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
BRAVE PEOPLE OF UKRAINE.
AS THEY COURAGEOUSLY DEFEND
THEIR COUNTRY AGAINST PUTIN'S
TYRANNY AS THEY FIGHT FOR THEIR
FREEDOM.
BUT WE SHOULDN'T IGNORE WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE RUN UP TO
PUTIN'S INVASION.
WAIVING SANCTIONS ON RUSSIAN
PIPELINES WHILE ELIMINATING OIL
PRODUCTION HERE AT HOME.
FOCUSING ON POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS RATHER THAN MILITARY
READINESS.
REACTING TO WORLD EVENTS INSTEAD
OF DRIVING THEM.
WEAKNESS ON THE WORLD STAGE HAS
A COST.
AND THE PRESIDENT'S APPROACH TO
FOREIGN POLICY HAS CONSISTENTLY
BEEN TOO LITTLE TOO LATE.
IT'S TIME FOR AMERICA TO ONCE
AGAIN PROJECT CONFIDENCE.
IT'S TIME TO BE DECISIVE.
IT'S TIME TO LEAD.
BUT WE CAN'T PROJECT STRENGTH
ABROAD IF WE'RE WEAK AT HOME.
AND THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO
DISCUSS WITH YOU TONIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT AND DEMOCRATS IN
CONGRESS HAVE SPENT THE LAST
YEAR EITHER IGNORING THE ISSUES
FACING AMERICANS OR MAKING THEM
WORSE.
THEY WERE WARNED THAT SPENDING
TRILLIONS WOULD LEAD TO SOARING
INFLATION.
THEY WERE TOLD THAT THEIR
ANTI-ENERGY POLICIES WOULD SEND
GAS PRICES TO NEW HEIGHTS.
BUT THEY PLOWED AHEAD ANYWAY.
RAISING THE PRICE AT THE PUMP BY
50% AND PUSHING INFLATION TO A
40-YEAR HIGH.
FOUR DECADES AGO WHEN OUR NATION
WAS LAST REELING FROM INFLATION,
I WAS A YOUNG, WORKING MOM JUST
STARTING OUT.
MY HUSBAND KEVIN WORKED DAYS
WHILE I WATCHED OUR GIRLS.
AND THEN WE WOULD LITERALLY
SWITCH.
WE WOULD PASS IN THE YARD AS HE
WAS COMING HOME AND I WAS
LEAVING TO WORK EVENINGS AT THE
LOCAL GROCERY STORE.
FROM ACROSS THE CHECK OUT
COUNTER I SAW THE PAIN OF
INFLATION ON MY NEIGHBORS'
FACES.
I SAW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN PRICES
RISE FASTER THAN WAGES.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES INFLATION IS A, QUOTE,
HIGH CLASS PROBLEM.
I CAN TELL YOU IT'S AN EVERYBODY
PROBLEM.
I SAW MOMS AND DADS' PAY CHECKS
BUY THEM LESS AND LESS.
I WATCHED WORKING PEOPLE CHOOSE
WHICH ESSENTIALS TO TAKE HOME
AND WHICH ONES TO LEAVE BEHIND.
AND NOW PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
DECISIONS HAVE A WHOLE NEW
GENERATION FEELING THAT SAME
PAIN.
WHEN I TOOK THE OATH OF OFFICE
FIVE YEARS AGO, I PROMISED
IOWANS I WOULD NEVER LOSE SIGHT
OF WHO I WAS WORKING FOR, THAT I
WOULDN'T BECOME DETACHED FROM
THE PROBLEMS THEY WERE FACING.
FROM THE PROBLEMS THAT I HAD
FACED MYSELF.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO CHECK
GROCERIES TO SEE WHAT HIGH
INFLATION DOES TO PEOPLE.
YOU JUST NEED TO STEP OUTSIDE OF
THE D.C. BUBBLE.
TALK TO AMERICANS ABOUT WHAT'S
ON THEIR MINDS.
ASK THEM, WHAT ARE YOUR
CONCERNS?
WHAT KEEPS YOU UP AT NIGHT?
AND THEY'LL TELL YOU.
AND I CAN TELL YOU WHAT'S NOT ON
THAT LIST.
THEY WON'T TELL YOU THAT
SPENDING TRILLIONS MORE AND
BANKRUPTING THEIR CHILDREN IS
THE ANSWER TO THEIR PROBLEMS.
THEY WON'T TELL YOU THAT WE
SHOULD BE PAYING PEOPLE NOT TO
WORK.
AND THEY CERTAINLY WON'T TELL
YOU THAT WE SHOULD GIVE BILLIONS
IN TAX GIVEAWAYS TO MILLIONAIRES
AND BILLIONAIRES IN DEMOCRAT
CONTROLLED STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA, NEW YORK, AND NEW
JERSEY.
BUT THAT'S WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN PUSHING
FOR OVER THE LAST YEAR.
AND THAT'S ALL PART OF BUILD
BACK BETTER.
THANKFULLY, THE PRESIDENT'S
AGENDA DIDN'T PASS BECAUSE EVEN
MEMBERS OF HIS OWN PARTY SAID
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
WELL, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHARE
THAT VIEW.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
IT'S NOT JUST WITH D.C.
SPENDING.
AMERICANS ARE TIRED OF A
POLITICAL CLASS TRYING TO REMAKE
THIS COUNTRY INTO A PLACE WHERE
AN ELITE FEW TELL EVERYONE ELSE
WHAT THEY CAN AND CANNOT SAY.
WHAT THEY CAN AND CANNOT BLEEFB.
THEY ARE TIRED OF PEOPLE
PRETENDING THE WAY TO END RACISM
IS BY CATEGORIZING EVERYBODY BY
THEIR RACE.
THEY'RE TIRED OF POLITICIANS WHO
TELL PARENTS THEY SHOULD SIT
DOWN.
BE SILENT.
LET GOVERNMENT CONTROL THEIR
KIDS' EDUCATION AND FUTURE.
FRANKLY, THEY ARE TIRED OF THE
THEATER WHERE POLITICIANS DO ONE
THING WHEN THE CAMERAS ARE
ROLLING AND ANOTHER WHEN THEY
BELIEVE YOU CAN'T SEE THEM.
WHERE GOVERNORS AND MAYORS
ENFORCE MANDATES BUT DON'T
FOLLOW THEM.
WHERE ELECTED LEADERS TELL THEIR
CITIZENS TO STAY HOME WHILE THEY
SNEAK OFF TO FLORIDA FOR SUN AND
FUN.
WHERE THEY DEMAND THAT YOUR
CHILD WEAR A MASK BUT THEY GO
MASKLESS.
SO YOU'VE HEARD THE EXCUSES.
THEY WERE JUST HOLDING THEIR
BREATH.
BUT IT'S THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHO
ARE WAITING TO EXHALE, WAITING
FOR THE INSANITY TO STOP.
WE NOW LIVE IN A COUNTRY WHERE
VIOLENT CRIME IS OUT OF CONTROL.
LIBERAL PROSECUTORS ARE LETTING
CRIMINALS OFF EASY.
AND MANY PROMINENT DEMOCRATS
STILL WANT TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
YOU KNOW, IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERYTHING IS BACKWARDS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
REQUIRES VACCINES FOR AMERICANS
WHO WANT TO GO TO WORK OR
PROTECT THIS COUNTRY.
BUT NOT FOR MIGRANTS WHO
ILLEGALLY CROSS THE BORDER.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TREATS
PARENTS LIKE DOMESTIC TERRORISTS
BUT LOOTERS AND SHOPLIFTERS ROAM
FREE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE LEFT TO
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE THE ENEMY.
THIS IS NOT THE SAME COUNTRY IT
WAS A YEAR AGO.
THE PRESIDENT TRIED TO PAINT A
DIFFERENT PICTURE TONIGHT, BUT
HIS ACTIONS OVER THE LAST 12
MONTHS DON'T MATCH THE RHETORIC.
IT'S NOT WHAT HE PROMISED WHEN
HE TOOK OFFICE.
BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THAT
WAY.
THERE IS AN ALTERNATIVE.
ACROSS THE NATION, REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS AND LEGISLATORS ARE
SHOWING AMERICANS WHAT
CONSERVATIVE LEADERSHIP LOOKS
LIKE, WHAT IT MEANS TO RESPECT
THE PEOPLE WE SERVE, TO HEAR
THEM OUT, TO STAND UP FOR THEM,
AND WALK ALONGSIDE THEM.
WE KNOW THAT OUR PROBLEMS
REQUIRE BOLD ACTION BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT BOLD ACTION DOESN'T
HAVE TO MEAN GOVERNMENT ACTION.
IT'S AMERICANS MAKING THEIR OWN
DECISIONS FOR THEIR OWN FAMILIES
AND FUTURE.
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS FACE THE
SAME COVID-19 VIRUS HEAD ON.
WE HONORED YOUR FREEDOMS AND SAW
RIGHT AWAY THAT LOCKDOWNS AND
SCHOOL CLOSURES CAME WITH THEIR
OWN SIGNIFICANT COST THAT
MANDATES WEREN'T THE ANSWER.
AND WE ACTUALLY LISTENED TO THE
SCIENCE ESPECIALLY WITH KIDS IN
MASKS AND KIDS IN SCHOOLS.
WHAT HAPPENED AND IS STILL
HAPPENING TO OUR CHILDREN OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS IS
UNCONSCIONABLE.
LEARNING LOSS, ISOLATION,
ANXIETY, DEPRESSION, AND SO MANY
STATES OUR KIDS HAVE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND AND SO MANY WILL NEVER
CATCH UP.
THAT'S WHY IOWA WAS THE FIRST
STATE IN THE NATION TO REQUIRE
THAT SCHOOLS OPEN THEIR DOORS.
I WAS ATTACKED BY THE LEFT.
I WAS ATTACKED BY THE MEDIA.
BUT IT WASN'T A HARD CHOICE.
IT WAS THE RIGHT CHOICE.
AND KEEPING SCHOOLS OPEN IS ONLY
THE START OF THE PRO PARENT, PRO
FAMILY REVOLUTION THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE LEADING IN IOWA
AND STATES ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
REPUBLICANS BELIEVE THAT PARENTS
MATTER.
IT WAS TRUE BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
AND IT HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
IMPORTANT TO SAY OUT LOUD.
PARENTS MATTER.
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW AND TO
HAVE A SAY IN WHAT THEIR KIDS
ARE BEING TAUGHT.
FAMILIES ALSO HAVE EVERY RIGHT
TO LIVE IN A SAFE AND SECURE
COMMUNITY.
AND THAT BEGINS WITH A SAFE AND
SECURE COUNTRY.
BUT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
REFUSED TO SECURE OUR BORDER.
THEY'VE REFUSED TO PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES TO STOP HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
TO STOP THE STAGGERING INFLUX OF
DEADLY DRUGS COMING INTO OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
THEY'VE REFUSED TO PROTECT YOU.
WITH TEXAS AND ARIZONA LEADING
THE WAY, I ALONG WITH REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS FROM SEVERAL STATES
HAVE SENT RESOURCES TO THE
BORDER, AND WE'VE ACTUALLY GONE
TO THE BORDER.
SOMETHING THAT OUR PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT HAVE YET TO DO
SINCE TAKING OFFICE.
ON THE ECONOMY THE CONTRAST
COULDN'T BE MORE STARK.
WHILE DEMOCRATS IN D.C. ARE
SPENDING TRILLIONS, SENDING
INFLATION SOARING, REPUBLICAN
LEADERS AROUND THE COUNTRY ARE
BALANCING BUDGETS AND CUTTING
TAXES.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT MONEY SPENT
ON MAIN STREET IS BETTER THAN
MONEY SPENT ON BUREAUCRACY.
TODAY I SIGNED LEGISLATION THAT
ELIMINATES IOWA'S TAX ON
RETIREMENT INCOME AND SETS OUR
TAX RATE AT 3.9%.
THAT'S LESS THAN HALF OF WHAT IT
WAS JUST FOUR YEARS AGO.
IT SHOULDN'T COME AS A SURPRISE
THAT OUT OF THE TOP 20 STATES
WITH THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT
RATES, 17 HAVE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS.
REPUBLICANS MAY NOT HAVE THE
WHITE HOUSE, BUT WE'RE DOING
WHAT WE CAN TO FILL THE
LEADERSHIP VACUUM.
AND ON THE ISSUES THAT ARE
AFFECTING AMERICANS, REPUBLICANS
ARE LEADING.
WE'RE STANDING UP FOR PARENTS
AND KIDS.
WE'RE STANDING UP FOR LIFE.
WE'RE KEEPING OUR COMMUNITIES
SAFE AND THANKING THOSE IN
UNIFORM.
WE'RE FIGHTING TO RESTORE
AMERICA'S ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
AND THAT INCLUDES FUELS.
WE'RE GETTING PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK NOT PAYING THEM TO STAY
HOME.
MOST OF ALL, WE ARE RESPECTING
YOUR FREEDOM.
BEHIND ME STAND IOWA'S CAPITOL
WHERE WE DISPLAY OUR STATE
MOTTO, OUR LIBERTIES WE PRIZE
AND OUR RIGHTS WE WILL MAINTAIN.
AND THOSE AREN'T JUST EMPTY
WORDS.
IT'S A BELIEF THAT THE GREATNESS
OF THIS STATE AND THIS COUNTRY
LIES IN OUR PEOPLE NOT
GOVERNMENT.
YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WAKE UP
EVERY MORNING AND WORRY ABOUT
THE NEXT THING THE GOVERNMENT IS
GOING TO DO TO YOU, YOUR
BUSINESS, OR YOUR CHILDREN.
IF WE AS ELECTED LEADERS ARE
DOING OUR JOB, THEN THE
GOVERNMENT IS WORKING WELL BUT
OPERATING IN THE BACKGROUND.
IT'S SUPPORTING THE INGENUITY
AND SPIRIT OF OUR PEOPLE NOT
DROWNING THEM OUT.
IT'S KEEPING THEM SAFE, NOT
RESTRICTING THEIR FREEDOM.
THAT'S WHAT I BELIEVE.
THAT'S WHAT REPUBLICANS BELIEVE.
AND THAT'S WHAT REPUBLICANS ARE
DOING.
I AM SO BLESSED TO BE THE
GOVERNOR OF IOWA WHERE PEOPLE
ARE HUMBLE, HARD WORKING, AND
PATRIOTIC.
WE TAKE CARE OF EACH OTHER AND,
YES, WE ARE AS THEY SAY IOWA
NICE.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE FROM
IOWA TO SEE THAT THOSE ARE THE
VALUES OF AMERICA AT ITS BEST.
ALL OF AMERICA.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS, I PUT
MY FAITH IN IOWANS AND THEY
HAVEN'T LET ME DOWN.
I ENCOURAGE THIS PRESIDENT TO DO
THE SAME, TO PUT HIS FAITH IN
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WHO
HAVE NEVER WAVERED IN YOUR
BELIEF IN THIS COUNTRY
REGARDLESS OF WHO LEADS IT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU'VE SHOWN
THAT THE SOUL OF AMERICA ISN'T
ABOUT WHO LIVES IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
IT'S MEN AND WOMEN LIKE YOU IN
EVERY CORNER OF THIS NATION WHO
ARE WILLING TO STEP UP AND TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR YOUR
COMMUNITIES, FOR YOUR NEIGHBORS,
AND ULTIMATELY FOR YOURSELVES BY
THAT MOST IMPORTANT MEASURE AT
LEAST, THE STATE OF OUR UNION